The traditional approach, which I'll call the
greedy approach, in constructing distributed hash table is
when you want to place a key value, you pick a node, n, where n is
very close to key. And now, if you want to retrieve a given key,
K, the algorithm you know is going to be, you want to go to a node N,
which is closest to this key K, because
that is the algorithm that is being used for
placing, so for retrieval you just do the reverse.
When you want a key K, you go to
a node which is closest to key K. That's
how these routing tables get populated at different nodes
in the distributed system at the user level. So
the routing table at A says that these are
the known peers to me whose node IDs I know and I know their mapping of the node
ID to the IP addresses. Now the node space
may be much bigger than the number entries I have
in my routing table. So what do I do
if I want to communicate with a node whose node
ID I know, but I don't have a mapping
for that node ID with respect to the IP address.
Basically the routing table at every node is
just saying these are the nodes that I
know how to communicate with directly. That is
all the nodes that are reachable from node A.
Because, at the user level, I have a mapping between the virtual node ID that is
used in the DHT and the IP address
that corresponds to it. And remember that IP address
is the only thing that the operating system is going
to understand. And therefore I know how to communicate with node
60, because I can give the IP address that corresponds to
node 60 when I want to send a message to node
60. Similarly for 79. Over here, node B knows how
to communicate with 60, knows how to communicate with 109. And
if these are the only entries that are in the routing
tables of A and B, these are the ones to which
node A knows how to communicate directly. What if I want to go to some other
node that is not in my routing my table yet? For example let's say
that I am trying to retrieve a key, 58 or 59. I know
that 58 or 59, in terms of the DST construction, it's
most likely stored in some node whose ID
is very close to this key. Now in my table I have a node ID 60, close enough to
the key that I'm looking for. So what I'm going to hope is that if I am looking
for this particular key, 58 or 59, good chance
that the key value pair that corresponds to 58
or 59 is stored in this node ID 60.
So that's the one that I'm going to communicate with.
It's possible that 58 is actually stored in
a node ID 58, in which case my hope is the desired
destination that I want to reach to is known to this peer,
60, who is close to the node number 58. So in other words,
if I want to communicate with node number 58, my best bet
is to communicate with node number 60 with
the hope that 60 may actually know how
to communicate with node number 58, because ultimately
I'm hoping that that's where this particular key value
pair may be actually stored. On the other hand, if the key that I am looking for
is 80 or 81, then I'll say well, chances are this key is toward a node
ID 79 for whom I have a mapping. Or if I go to him, he might know how to get to
node number 80 which may be actually storing this key 80, which may be actually
storing this key 80. So in other words, in
the greedy approach what we're going to do is
in placing a key value we're going to place
the key value pair at a node N where N
is equal to K, ideally, or close to K. Similarly, if I want to retrieve
a key K, I'm going to go to a node N, where N is either equal to K if I know
how to get to it from my routing table. Or get to a node that is close enough to
the desired N. In this case, the desired N is 58 or 59, but the one that I
can get to is 60, and my hope is that when I get to 60 he will know how to get
me to node number 58 or 59. Or even better, he may be the one that is storing
this particular key value pair that corresponds to the key
that I'm looking for. So in other words, in the
greedy approach we are trying to get to our desired
destination as quickly as possible with the minimum number of
hops to get to the desired destination. And when
I say the number of hops, it is at the
level of the virtual overlay network, not in terms of
the physical network. Because at the user level have no
idea how many hops my message may actually take
going from source to destination. All that we are saying
is at the user level we are trying to minimize
the number of hops to get to the desired destination.